[Music] I
never thought I'd be
wearing them right away. In fact, if I was going to get that wet,
I probably should have come earlier. I don't understand why you cut off your clothes to take a bath,
huh?  It's hard to see how good it is to have skin without scales. I don't think it's
bad. If that's the case, then I don't think there's much to
say about the appearance of the ears or anything. I'm just
a little jealous.
But I don't really understand.  I think it suits you, but I
think you should learn a little more about how girls feel. Well, I think Goblin Slayer is fine as is, but I think it's
embarrassing if people look at her too much.  Well
then, why don't you just go get some fish from the river?
[Music]
Oh, that's amazing. Adventurers always
come to places like this.
So this time it's my
sister's wedding, so I have to make it look pretty.I used to
think about that a lot when I was a child, but I still
admire you.Oh, look, I'm
not that adventurer, please
don't tell me, Princess Ao.  Or don't make me say anything about your wife, it
's okay if you're cold, my wife.